- Well, John Malkovich is on your album.
I find that crazy.
What kind of happenstance was that
that he ended up on your album?
- So Pete Berg invited me to be a part
of his movie called "Mile 22"
and we were acting together
and, you know, whatever time off we had,
he was just talking about
his stories from theater
and connected and he's
my mentor, now I'm here.
- I love that, he's like
one of my favorite actor.
- He is the best, he's family, yeah.
- And this is even more random, Mike.
Is it true that Mike
Tyson was an inspiration
for this album?
- Yes.
- Please tell me how?
- You know, he's doing
these podcasts these days,
I'm a fan of him to start with.
- Oh I didn't know that.
- Yeah, and I was just
going through his podcasts
and some of the things
he said, things like,
before I, you know, fight how he feels,
like, connected to that.
- Oh, do you see the stage
is a boxing arena? Like...
- You know, I think it's
just about the gap between,
you know, the emotions you
use onstage and offstage.
- Yeah, do you kinda become,
my mother was laughs at
me because she's like,
"I can tell."
It's like, literally right
when I finished the song,
then I become like the bubbly me offstage.
- But during the song I'm
like very in the zone,
your like that as well?
- Yes.
- We all have a sush of fears
- We all do and that's what "Alpha"
is about on my album, so...
- I love that.
That's why you titled it that.
- Yes.
- I love that, is that where
you feel the most powerful?
Like, in like...
- Onstage.
- Yeah.
- I call like, I'm a performer,
so that's where I feel comfortable
and that's what I love doing.
- Yeah, I love your vibe,
I was watching while I
was getting ready today
and I was watching
rehearsals and I was like,
"Oh my."
- You didn't.
- I did, I was watching and
I was like, "Oh my gosh."
And all the dancing, it's so cool
it's very, very cool.
- Yes, I had fun doing it.
- And I love it too 'cause it
starts off and you're like,
"I don't wanna run it."
Anyway, I like the whole performance.